here we go I know you're so excited hope
you're as excited as we are I'm getting
in the yoga position the yogi yeah Yoga
Yoga this is Yogi Bear very much by
popular demand I had no desire to see
this movie what's your memory of Yogi
Bear did you like it yogi left no
impression like zero I didn't I didn't
hate it yeah I just have no thought
about it so now we have this movie that
it sounds like well at least I have a
thought about it's supposed to be bad
but yeah I I'm not gonna be super angry
if they do not stick to the yogi mythos
why is it Anna Faris in this oh I love
Anna Faris I hate it with cheese and
shit let's do this Yogi Bear so excited
[Music]
Jellystone Park that Malcolm Oh
excuse me this is from the SMN Club last
night Oh sucks swings are really amazing
Timberlake's doing a way better
Timberlake here's the guy really trying
somebody give me Barry Allen Barry Allen
you should watch the flash soldering
iron stab you in the face with a
soldering guy if Christopher Walken
comes in from country town there's smoke
behind a series of getting over this the
time it takes you to make this device
you have gone to the store bought a
picnic basket with your own choice of
fun this guy looks like he does not look
happy to be in this movie I don't
usually say this but someone did her
makeup weird and she looks weird
somebody spray tanned her face and face
only yeah you know I hope she's not just
the hot woman no cuz she is so fucking
funny I don't they actually do something
with her Doug it's Yogi Bear what are
you expecting out of this she's the only
good
in every scary movie we sold the
bottling rights to the water and like
Boclair oh well we made a fortune off of
that yeah and sinkhole Beauclair is a
great place to probably many kids
following this conversation following
this conversation this is no different
from any other performance I've seen
them in but you're right it looks
completely like just fuck this movie
yeah is the most entertaining part so
far only mayor of a small town you
actually don't own this park I was
talking to my pet turtle so what's the
big deal yogi I mean how can we can talk
but the turtle can't
Pocahontas rules it doesn't have to make
any sense fucking tree talks but the
animals didn't why there's no more
hand-drawn animations how's that copilot
seat feel a little wobbly like it's not
tied on very tight kinda like the script
yogi Yogi Bear so who is he on the flash
you know him yeah Oh Dan Aykroyd
yes yeah no Jimmy timber lavtf curry was
on the flash did you think that you just
had the Wilhelm scream is the worst use
of the house so like any minute he's
just gonna whip out shoot lively but if
you watch him and anything else anything
else that is always the performance he
gives which is why I love him all you
have to do is scratch their backside and
you've got a friend for life you try
that with people and all of a sudden
you're the weird girl on the bus and
nobody wants to sit next to okay good
they're making her funny I just kind of
let the movie to be about these so do I
not like it's a weird awkward romance in
the world's most grouchy guy ready to
fucking snap at a moment's notice and
the weird girl on the bus nobody wants
it next year all right we've rewritten
the movie yes and we'll submit him it
opens
with yogi getting shot and this just
about these two and he's just miserable
and she's just insane
yuan Senate of winter making a Christmas
movie - yeah I was like Hallmark
Christmas films you know change the name
to extreme Jellystone
it is very 90s I'm not extreme
Jellystone
I swear this is this is a 92 ramp John
only is it a 90 strip really looks like
a 90 like I want to say this movie was
made 19 looks like you came out the same
year as W right yes it feels like it's
in the W right universe okay all right
so is it a double tap or do I have to
president dog tag it's 20 seconds of my
life I want you to resurrect that twice
I give it back to me like ten minutes
[Laughter]
it's the mic oh my god we just get to
that joke for my kids a hug robot kids a
hug
it makes a bonus on thank you we're more
than happy to collect those after the
fireworks but those great day fireworks
as well your Park is closing and launch
fireworks and though the day what's
wrong with you
ladies and gentleman you may have
noticed we dropped acid in the kool-aid
that's a crowd that was told to
applause so you're not being told what
you're applauding - he probably just
roasts birds alive Bharath wavy skeleton
lying across 12 people were killed today
and 50 injured that a fireworks mishap
adjust its Yogi's job to pick up all the
decapitated head oh yeah fireworks well
if no one else is gonna eat it mr.
Ranger aye aye
I offer my letter of resignation we were
paying you oh yeah I'm on the payroll
what the hell how does this Park work
how smart are you now dance of a million
tiny like that's Rico but there's no as
he walks by just ships it with you yeah
and it has no reaction of space walks
off no reaction white face this is the
story of a serial killer I need to see
Ben's dad I am going to forage for food
in the wild I will ride a water buffalo
like Lao Tzu into the sunset I will say
this it is kind of impressive they are
really not like that once if I ever you
member motley like tricked into thinking
they were there yeah Oh
could this get any worse
a bad joke that's how I cook it worse
I'm just a bad joke that's about one of
the worst jokes on the planet if not
number one yeah like we're putting that
many of these come on listen anyway
we're starting our own brand of
eco-terrorism nope no I will not do
another Nancy that's right I'm so
fucking bored I'm judging the font I'm
pretty convinced these are all fake
names we're gonna be seeing in the
credits
okay so we just watched a patch of fog
no much like the real Yogi Berra kind of
left not much if this movie feels like
yeah 2010 my ass this movie feels like
15 years too late
clearly 1995 to 98 is where this movie
belong it gave us lots of fun imaginary
ways of seeing these characters die I
mean I was thinking a lot of funny ways
that the Ranger could kill yogi
and yogi would eat boo boo and they
would all just do like a suicide pact or
something but it's like yes yeah I can't
be that upset of it you know that would
have been but that's kind of sad because
that means it would have forced me to
have an emotion I got up into fucking
Yogi Bear by
you